whether or not you personally care for
the fallout and elder scrolls games you
can't deny how those series have changed
the face of open-world RPGs to that end
Bethesda director Todd Howard will be
receiving a lifetime achievement award
at next month's game developers choice
awards Todd Howard has been with
Bethesda for 22 years ever since he
literally knocked on the front door with
his college resume in hand he's being
honored for his innovative contributions
to open world gameplay and game
development Meghan scavi o who manages
the awards stated the elder scrolls and
Fallout series present gamers with fully
realized world's filled with vast
landscapes and mystery at every corner
we're proud to honor the visionary
developer for his leadership in creating
these universes when you're completely
captivated by these detailed worlds it's
easy to forget the level of dedicated
work and creativity that went into every
square inch this award reflects on the
amazing craft of Todd Howard and his
team and making worlds as real as
anything on earth Todd Howard shares the
honor with the likes of developer Peter
Molyneux and Final Fantasy creator
hironobu sakaguchi so this is quite the
prestigious award congratulations from
GameSpot mr. Howard we still have some
fallout 4 endings to see
you